investigators used DNA from a tree we've
been talking about this all morning to
help solve a crime it happened after a
young mother from Missouri disappeared
three years ago 48 Hours correspondent
Peter Van Sant shows how investigators
used an unlikely clue to bring her
killer to Justice
[Applause]
on October 10 2019 23 year old Joseph
ellage reported his wife mungshi ji
missing so you said that uh took her
purse with her right yeah at the time
Dan Knight was the prosecuting attorney
in Missouri's Boone County
Joe ellich said that on October 8th he'd
gone to sleep with monkey at about 11 11
30 or so and then he woke up the next
morning and then he noticed that monk
she was gone vanished initially ellage
told police and CBS affiliate krcg that
he believed his wife may have left him
and their one-year-old daughter for
another man I know she was talking to
somebody else on the side and whatever
she's doing I just hope she's safe
Joe ellidge's attorney Scott Rosenbloom
he actually discovered that she was
involved in an online relationship
how did he find out he went on her one
of her devices and started reading it we
were trying our best to leave no Stones
Unturned
there were a lot of stones police
searched the couple's apartment and
found some puzzling evidence including
this muddy pair of Joe ellij's boots
taken into evidence on a hunch just in
case down the road they might be
relevant something was amiss yes and
they they sensed it eledge's boots did
become relevant thanks to several
juniper tree needles stuck to the souls
and these needles where did they come
from we had three needles that came from
that tree right there
I thought it
d-a from these juniper trees helped
solve this crime I've never heard of
anything like this before in my entire
career at 48 hours
Peter Van sand joins us now Peter wait
wait so the Buick had the needle needle
and the needles were from that tree yes
why was that important well
juniper trees are one of the few on
Earth that have a unique DNA profile
just like human beings each tree has its
own profile so when they discovered this
shallow grave out there in this Grove of
juniper trees and we go out with a
scientist from Missouri Botanical Garden
he has a special tool they took samples
they got some of these needles did their
DNA test and then tested against those
muddy boots that you saw because there
were some needles on that perfect match
oh wow and so it's just like having
blood evidence DNA about you they had
they had him he was at the gravesite
which forced the defense to change their
story about not just a juniper tree that
that that's the keep it specific really
cool I've never heard anything like this
Peter Van Sant thank you very much no we
have not you can see Peter's full report
the tree that helped solve a murder on
48 hours tomorrow night at 10 9 Central
right here on CBS and on our streaming
service Paramount Plus